President Trump is leading calls for
unity following the shooting we can all
agree that we are blessed to be
Americans that our children deserve to
grow up in a nation of safety and peace
and that we are strongest when we are
unified and when we work together for
the common good
Republicans and Democrats will have a
chance to show that tonight at the
annual Congressional baseball game the
contest draws thousands of fans each
year it's been a tradition for more than
a century proceeds and donations go to
charity Jan Crawford is overlooking
Nationals Park in Washington where
tonight's game will be played Jan good
morning good morning Charlie you know
there aren't many bipartisan traditions
left in Washington anymore but for a
hundred and eight years the
Congressional baseball game has been one
of them and that show of unity is why
despite yesterday's shooting the game is
on the skills on the field while not
major league might surprise you and when
Republicans and Democrats square off on
the diamond the level of competition is
intense
Nathaniel lakish has been covering the
Congressional baseball game for five
years they take it very seriously with a
lot of smack talk and raikage says one
of the most determined players on the
field is Louisiana Republican Steve
Scalise Scalise was shot in the hip
Wednesday while practicing for tonight's
showdown he is one of the toughest
competitors out there one of the hardest
workers I did tell Joe that I loved him
before the game and I loved him after
the game but during the game we're gonna
play to win Wednesday afternoon the
managers of the two teams Republican
Congressman Joe Barton and Democrat Mike
Doyle announced that despite the
shooting the game was on it will be play
bald the Congressional baseball game was
created in 1909 by Pennsylvania
Congressman John Tanner a former pitcher
for the Chicago white stockings wore a
depression and the business of Congress
sometimes canceled the games
when the teams did play it played hard
and her keeps women started playing in
1993 representative Linda Sanchez has
played for 15 years
she says the game is a chance to shed
partisanship it's a chance to kind of
take a break from the polarized
atmosphere of legislating and just have
a little bit of fun with our colleagues
and something that's her national
pastime now tonight's game will actually
be a tiebreaker for the two teams
Republicans and Democrats each have won
39 games lost 39 games and tied once and
then after yesterday's shooting they've
actually added a new charity to the
recipients will be getting the proceeds
from tonight's game the Capitol Police
Memorial Fund Jeff no doubt this will be
the biggest audience they've ever had I
hope so it holds 50,000 be great and if
those seats all are all filled and does
the score really matter you're right I
know it's about the other tonight and
watching butts or matters people want to
win yes
tied at 39 there you go our 24 hour
streaming network cbsn we'll have live
coverage of tonight's Congressional
baseball game beginning at 7:00 Eastern
six central you can watch on the CBS
News app or at CBS news.com